as ccsd students prepare for classes on
monday
other kids have already begun the new
charter school explore academy near lone
mountain and rancho opened during the
pandemic
welcome back students in person today
for the first time
kate houston stop by the school i like
that we can actually be back into person
school
it's much better because i can actually
talk to my friends explore academy
is buzzing with excitement as more than
300 students head back to school
i'm feeling excited because i get to see
my friends in person
but i'm also feeling pretty nervous
because i still have to get adjusted to
middle school
i'm quite excited for going into high
school it's a new experience
it seems it seems quite fun
this is the official first day for
teachers as well since the pandemic kept
them from campus and their students
it's like the energy is through the roof
pe teacher corby chaney says there's a
sense of relief that students can attend
in person
they're really excited to learn which is
pretty cool you know compared to
different years
you know before the pandemic it wasn't
the same this is a whole new film well
everyone is happy to be back on this
campus
their permanent school location is still
under construction
material shortages and permit delays are
keeping explore academy at a temporary
spot
through the first term one challenge
after another one struggle and you know
but we are getting through it
we're very resilient he has three goals
that you want to do here
although the start of the year is
coinciding with an increase in cases and
restrictions
chaney says they're grateful to be back
with their students
teaching virtually had a tremendous
amount of challenges
so being back here in school it just
feels like we're where we should be
kate houston 8 news now explore academy
currently teaches grades 6 through 10.
they hope to expand to 12th grade
in the coming years